ah day in the life of the software
engineer this is what it's like these
days yeah that's right
pretending to wake up in the morning he
was my kids pillow because he's
quarantined in somebody else's house so
extra pillows we actually the reality is
I woke up at like 8:00 went back to
sleep woke up again at about 10:00 I got
a little cold put on this robe and it's
probably isn't what you expected huh
but this is this is a reality no no
fancy music no pretending everything's
cool it just is what it is I enjoy it I
like this this is fine but down let's
let's go with a little more so what do I
do when I get up up usually I stumble
out of my room well wait a second let's
back up first of all I get out of this
bed here sometimes get dressed and then
I go start up my computer that's what I
do and well it's starting up actually
it's usually already running because I
fell asleep watching YouTube the night
before so usually I don't actually start
up my computer so I wonder through my
apartment towards the kitchen area and
consider maybe going and getting some
Sun out on the balcony or something and
just don't and get into this kitchen
area and and turn on the Keurig make
sure I have coffee left confirm that I
don't need to go get more coffee I don't
know I'm saying that obviously I
remember from yesterday if I have coffee
or not but you know that's that's the
stand of these videos use a thermos
that's right
keeps it nice and hot make sure you burn
your tongue lose some of those that
tongue things because you're gonna get
your tongue burn and I don't know what
else what else do I do
I don't know sometimes I exercise for a
while do a few things but really there's
not much to do because uh oh yes right
I'm quarantine so that's what the
day-in-the-life
software engineer is sometimes I go into
this extra room over here don't pay
attention to the mess or do I don't care
but it's just an extra room where I have
lots of junk that's where I do all my I
don't know what do I do in there I don't
even know all right so then I wonder
back over here to this computer area
have a nice comfortable seat on this
Serta chair which is Serta Serta
leathery and generally makes my butt
sweat so it actually kind of sucks it's
not the best chair but then I just sit
here and I mess around and sometimes I
times I program sometimes I don't I
don't know what more do you want to know
that's the life right now so mainly
right now I'm working on I don't know
what the hell am i working on I have
several programs neither of them are
really taking off some of them have some
stars in github etc etc I get lots of
spam calls on my phone often from
recruiters I wouldn't really call the
recruiter when spam because I kind of
signed up for him but I put my resume
out there but generally well they're
getting better for awhile they're like
oh hey my name is so-and-so and I'm from
X and X recruiting you want to fly
halfway across the world for an
interview what no I want to fly halfway
across the world for an interview
it sounds like the worst idea ever but
more recently they've been offering
remote stuff which I declined still
because
I don't really want a job I kind of like
working from home and not having to
worry about other people's agendas it's
sort of nice so I don't know I don't
know what you were expecting but what
you got was a whole bunch of honesty I
hope you have a good day thanks for
watching
peace out